yacht au monde c'est ce que dit aux
joueurs de se trouve dans une forêt
[ __ ] de mega glauque de la mort 1 pour
un super jeu d'horreur première chose
nous leur son dec bien ça oui oui vous
ne rêvez pas alors à la recherche d'âmes
ya un os vous mes chers à main
blood derf ça fait très très peur cet
homme ce meurtrier fait des tags
c'est un gangster un meurtre et
gangsters jean petit âne dans les
parages
non bon jusque jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il n'y a pas d'esprit à moins
que cette arme soit un esprit qui
m'étonnerait grandement un bien un qui
veut un neuf je ne veux pas un f
et j'en ai deux pour toi hayek live en
fait c'était un adolescent rebelle s'est
déguisé en lapin le mec qu'a pas du tout
un problème
j'aime pas la vie je vais détailler dans
le tunnel
un bruit de train ohlala j'ai tellement
peur à essen mouture and back watts
qu'elle cet homme
non mais c'est lui là qu'on doit dégager
gbagbo tient bof moi pour ce colloque
est bien ça s'annonce super nul comme
you what the fuck
mais [ __ ] mais sous ces fichus esprit
la console est bon gars le logo le plus
terrorisant du monde
un mélange entre call of duty gosse et
y'en a pas qu'elle signifie dior snrt et
stephen walt disney ou tuer un vilain
lapin tu te tais l'époque oui aux u9 à
sauver je suis là pour toi en arrête
arrête je sais que tu es triste je sais
que tu es morte c'est normal d'être
triste mais je suis là pour te sauver
regard d'un oeuf un oeuf
comment je t'aurais suscite une âme nul
pour la peine je vais manger du sang oui
on a sauvé une âme à alléluia alors je
pense et des âmes qui ne pas léser les
sauver on l'a sauvé deux âmes
oh mon dieu nous sommes des saussaies
bain nous sommes des soul 120 nous
sommes déçus pour gracier les sauveurs
d'un mr darcos est une map la limite ce
sont des cure dents portait en somme
et si je me retire est bon tout ça
entrer dans son jeu
à 3 jours 9 aïn melha que des âmes qui
crie campus nord crise et pas un petit
cri normal c'est genre quoi peut-être
des âmes de porc finalement oui un lapin
qui tuent des ports il est tout
s'éclaircit pas si tu prends un lapin
avec une hache qui obtient ce
psychopathe
on s'en fout tu veux jouer au foot avec
foi alors les questions de cette arme
jusqu'à 5 avr allez c'est parti
ce bon cru de porc
excusez moi je veux juste vous serez la
vie en vous donnant un oeuf suis
quelqu'un de gentil peut-être m'asseoir
dans ces fougères et faire un camping au
milieu d'esprit mais magnifique
à quelle bonne idée parce qu'elle crise
elle si elle est super jolie un peu tu
étais un sacré port un thé pas un petit
port cnrf allons fait danser est ce que
tu fais du sceau 2e pas du so2 et du
sceau de feu alors des mois cette
démarche-là des piles or je t'envoie un
neuf mois - chiant ou moi j'aime les
jeux vidéo cette fumée verte là on
dirait un pde de crapaud géant ou dirais
tout simplement de la fumée vers tous et
aussi oui oui c'est vrai quel est le
comble pour une âme de soul et les
autres
on a tous des problèmes c'est pas la
peine de crier sur tombe ici écoute moi
moi quand j'étais petit il y avait un
vilain lapin capa vous juste derrière
moi pour me mettre à coups de hache un
bon bah écoute et à léon l'ensemble est
parti juste là et je propose
transformant pas de calais qui bouge pas
espère voir noir c'est la fin ben un
jour tu avais juste un pq sur rails
je suis dans la maison après dormir dans
mon lit est ce que c'est un cauchemar